our political editor Beth Rigby was
listening to that statement so Beth what
did you make of it
well it was short and to the point Anna
wasn't it she uh the Prime Minister said
I cannot deliver the Mandate for which I
have been elected I have spoken to the
king I've notified him I'm resigning
this morning she met with graham Brady
and she says that she and the chair of
the 1922 party has agreed that the
leadership election will be completed
within the next week absolutely
Breakneck speed so they wanted to keep
her in post until that fiscal statement
clear that she could not survive that
she literally could not manage or leave
the party even for a couple of weeks
longer and they have decided between
them that Liz truss has to go she stood
down we will have a new prime minister
within a week by the end of next week
Liz truss is saying there will be a new
prime minister is an absolutely
astonishing finishing turn of events
Boris Johnson
ousted from number 10 in July Liz truss
elected she took up the post on
September the 5th and now here we are
six weeks later she's been forced to
stand down and now the question is who
is going to take over how will those
rules work we are going to have another
prime minister the third in what a
matter of three or four months within
the next week
well yes and let's reflect on on what a
moment this is as you were saying there
Beth extraordinary that we're going to
see yet another prime minister take over
after six extraordinary weeks of her
being in office at losing her Chancellor
losing her home secretary and having to
reverse key planks of her key policies
that's right Anna and let's just reflect
for a moment
on the attempt of Liz truss attempt of
her regime and and wear it all ended up
because it didn't have to go this way
actually in terms of the policy platform
she stood on the party like that party
members like that lots of MPS like that
they wanted tax cuts they wanted to go
for growth
but the staging and the the pitch
rolling of these plans was just done in
a way that didn't bring people with her
and as any prime minister any leader
knows you're only as strong as the
people uh that come with you that you
rule if you like by consent and buy
support and I think what happened with
Liz truss was she had won the party uh
membership over she had won the position
and with that she took absolute power
and I say that in the sense that she
decided to not include sunak
supporters in her cabinet she then
Unleashed an economic program which she
said went against treasury Orthodoxy in
fact she was quite critical I'm just
going to grab a Broly it's raining a bit
now she was quite critical of uh the
economic Orthodoxy of the treasury she
was critical in the leadership race of
the bank of England she thought she
could do things her way and then what
happened was that a statement came out
that mini budget it went further and
faster than people expected with more
than expected tax cuts 45 billion pounds
of unfunded tax cuts the markets gave
their verdict very quickly and it was
very bad for Liz trust so bad she had to
u-turn on her 45 Pence rate policy to
scrap the 45 Pence rate she then had to
U-turn a few days later on the entire
thing having sacked her Chancellor and
at that point we were saying it's a
matter of time this prime minister's
reputation is in to quote one former
Minister absolute tatters you then saw
the poll in from the public only one in
ten britons gave her a favorable rating
she had the worst ratings of any prime
minister since ratings began and then of
course in the polls labor just
absolutely charging ahead this is not a
recipe for sustainability for a prime
minister so in a way there was a sense
that the the game could be over and then
a series of unforced Errors I would say
over the past 48 Hours has just
precipitated her demise as I said there
was hopes she could stay on until
October the 31st just calm things down
it just simply became untenable and it
is nearly beyond belief that having
ousted Boris Johnson in July the
conservative party having picked his
trust has decided she is not up for the
job and now we have to see who will
replace her and there is going to be a
lot of horse trading now behind the
scenes between the likes of Rishi sunak
Penny mordant Jeremy Hunt who else Ben
Wallace swella bravaman resigning
yesterday clearly fancies her chances on
the right of the party I and what might
the party do well as I was reporting
this week there's talks about lifting
the nomination threshold above 100 100
and 20 MPS why might you do that because
you flush out other candidates and the
party really want wrong candidate I
think the fact that I don't have the
details yet I'm afraid but I think the
fact that the Prime Minister has said
the race will be completed by next week
so that's what eight nine days from now
suggests to me that it is going to be a
race just of the Parliamentary party I
don't think that that can go to members
during that time I was told that that
could be a problem by someone because
that might mean
um that there was a legal challenge
because it should go to members but
obviously Jake Barry the party chairman
has been in uh to number 10 and they've
clearly discussed all of this but what
an astonishing ton of events we thought
and we've been talking amongst ourselves
and we've been reporting it on
television too that her time was going
to be up as I said last night people had
decided her time was up the question was
the speed of the departure and I think
what happened in the Commons last night
the fracking debacle the chaos the whips
resigning and not resigning I think many
MPS just said we can't do this for a day
longer and they haven't she is out